una cumbre al más alto nivel el propio
presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
recibió al ministro de relaciones
exteriores chino wang yi en su visita a
turquía a continuación el representante
chino se reunió con su homólogo turco
mevlüt cavusoglu y éste no dudó en poner
sobre la mesa su preocupación por la
represión contra los rigores en china
transmitimos nuestra sensibilidad y
pensamientos sobre los turcos uigures
beijing y ankara aprobaron en diciembre
un acuerdo de extradición algo que
preocupa a los cerca de 40 mil
activistas figures que viven en turquía
sin embargo desde el gobierno turco han
negado que el acuerdo entre ambos países
vaya a suponer la devolución de uigures
a china mientras se celebraba la reunión
entre los cancilleres manifestantes se
reunieron en estambul y en ankara
gritando lemas como china dictador y
detengan el genocidio big ur cierren los
campos
algunos incluso ondeaban las banderas
azules y blancas del movimiento
independentista
del turkestán oriental nombre con el que
se conoce a chillán norman
estoy frustrado porque recibe turquía al
ministro de asuntos exteriores chino
están haciendo mucho daño al turkestán
oriental los chinos están haciendo mucho
daño estoy muy enfadado con los expertos
de la onu calculan que al menos un
millón de ovi gure si otros musulmanes
están recluidos en centros de detención
desde el noroeste de china esta semana
la unión europea estados unidos canadá y
reino unido- sancionaron los abusos de
china contra la minoría uigur desde
china niega las acusaciones y aseguran
que los complejos que estableció en la
región proporcionan cursos en los que
radican el extremismo islamista y el
separatismo